ich begrüße sie recht herzlich für dem
zweiten test video hallo und willkommen
zu einem neuen ikea food testvideo ihr
habt den titel wahrscheinlich schon
richtig gelesen heute machen wir keine
snacks und getränke sondern gebäck und
torten denn wenn man in der cafeteria
von ikea steht oder den mann spencer
oder nennt man das restaurant
es ist eine mischung aus allem ein gibt
es dort schon verschiedene kuchen und
torten und gebäck stücke aber wenn man
nach den kassen in diesem supermarkt
bereich geht gibt es noch so viel mehr
das ich noch nie gesehen habe und ich
wusste gar nicht dass ikea so viele sagt
also lebensmittel das ist eine ganz neue
welt für mich und ich bin wirklich so
gespannt wie es schmeckt und wieder
natürlich das hier ist nicht von ikea
gesponsert aber falls sie kein bock hat
auf dem sponsoring weiß wo ich wohne
verläuft ich bin völlig schockiert von
dem was es alles bei ikea an
lebensmitteln gibt was sie dir zum
beispiel dafür ihren eigenen kaffee
haben das hier ist gemeiner café
mittlere rüstung biologe stehen dem
moment but a second cup of coffee
wir beginnen natürlich erstmal mit dem
geruchstest nicht wie normaler kaffee
sieht aus wie normaler kaffee und wird
wahrscheinlich auch so wie normaler
kaffee schmecken ich mache ich mal ganz
kurz
wieviel warum man eigentlich wenn man
zwei löffel das gießen wir nun mit
heißem wasser aus dass da jetzt so
ziehen und wir warten bis er fertig ist
in den winter
[Musik]
war es ein ganz tolles aroma das ist der
kaffee milch morgens halb zehn in
deutschland prost irgendwie bin ich
stärkeren kaffee gebrüht leute was soll
ich sagen ist guter kaffee kann man
trinken dort auf jeden fall okay aber
trotzdem gibt es mich so dass ja kaffee
verkauft die sie was ich meine was ist
bei ikea passiert dass irgendwer gesagt
haben moment wir machen jetzt kaffee und
alle anderen so im raum wenn ihr mich
kennen wissen aber dass ich jetzt nicht
über das kaffeetrinken reden möchte
sondern über wieso zimtschnecken hab ich
mir immer wieder am ausgang geholt und
jetzt habe ich gesehen wie die firma wir
gehen auch ganz gut aus
ich war sehr überrascht weiß nicht wie
die rezeptur ist aber so sehen sie aus
wenn sie aus der packung kommen
tiefgefroren und so sehen sie nach dem
ofen aus ich hab noch nie so schöne
zimtschnecken gebacken und bildeten das
ist eine wunderschöne zimtschnecken sie
sind in der packung sechs stück mensch
toll jetzt ist aber die frage
schmecken sie mir genauso gut wie bei
ikea
verdammte axt ich hab sie sogar ein
bisschen zu lange offen gehabt hat man
sich wird gemüse selber zu machen ganz
erledigt ob zimtschnecken diesen keks
gab es auch an der kasse und eigentlich
sind wir uns ja alle einig subway macht
die besten cookies hier aber vielleicht
kommt ja jetzt die care um die ecke
positiv wie gesagt ein euro gekostet und
ist wirklich riesengroß einfach und erst
hofft umhin kommt also der segway cookie
ist noch besser aber am klavier sowie
davon essen und auge einfach so den
ganzen aber heimfeld leute ihr müsst
doch nicht beim verein macht ihr seid
doch besser als das das nächste wird
euch umhauen eine geile torte die ich
noch nie bei ikea gefehlt haben hat zu
einem massiv decke die so frech einfach
runter hängt wie so ein vorhang und ich
sag euch wenn die jetzt gut schmeckt
hoffe die kann man wieder einfrieren ich
mich kaputt warum rede ich mit einer
torte die hypo instagram versus realität
also ich meine dass mit dem puderzucker
ist ja süß gemeint aber ich weiß nicht
was damit passiert ist wenn ich jetzt
jemand in so ein geburtstagskuchen mit
briefen würde dann wackelt ihn doch
lieber selbst aber medici spray die von
der inside me don't know how ich gehe
mal wieder ganz kurz ein anderes
oberteil an weil ich will mich nicht
voll kleckern der mensch toll dort bauen
vorurteile mir das richtig peinlich wenn
ich sie mitbringen würde auf seinen
geburtstag und dann sieht die so aus ich
will einfach wieder wenigstens sind ihre
inneren werte gut und sehr sonnig und
probieren wir mal die süße kleine maus
hier ein geiler bis
sahne heidelberg in der füllung und
marzipan außen der biscuit boden ich bin
jetzt seit kelly torten experte der
boden hat zu viel pulver oder so
schmeckt so sauer und enttäuscht mich
leider bisher so ich brauch mal ein cafe
club elle das nächste faszinierende
produkt fertige pfannkuchen 12 fertig
gepackten etwas 12 an kuchen
tiefgefroren oder wie die schweden sagen
bank accor heißt die wirklich band
cordes wie das im namen also als sehr
wir vorschlagen sagen sie erdbeeren und
wahrscheinlich wären marmelade und
puderzucker
ich hab's nie gebacken und es ist so ich
zeig euch mal wie sie tiefgefroren
aussehen mein gott zielgruppen
unterschied er ein bisschen probieren
wir mal einen bankrott
gerne aufhalten also wie sagt man kaffee
schmeckt exakt wie meine kindheit in
meinem kindergarten oder hort grades ab
und zu verbuchen
die haben genau so geschmeckt mega
lecker ich mag zu diesen bilder
geschmack lebt und stabiler frank farian
und sagen nach diesem pankow habe ich so
lust auf kaffee des memory morgens with
laughter im cache chocolate cake also
klebriger zehn spielen kann ist mir das
nicht mal mehr backen muss man einfach
nur aufbauen das ist irgendwie so crazy
ich meine er sieht auch nicht so krass
aus nahm aber trotzdem im chaco h der
ist gut der ist nicht gut das ist die
zubereitung verpackung entfernen bei
raumtemperatur 30 minuten lang auftauen
also wenn das jetzt das leckerste ist
was ich jemals in meinem leben gegessen
habe dann wäre es schön nur sorry das
ist einfach nur keks teil wir hätten den
kuchen backen können haben wir aber
nicht das verdankt auch mal geil ich hab
zwar noch nicht bewertet aber das klingt
auf jeden fall eine 10 von 10
warum ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich
so was mag halb fester schokoladenkuchen
die schweden als nächstes aus der
kategorie muss man noch zuhause backen
was los und die sehen einfach so aus die
drei minuten erhitzen beim erhitzen
nicht auf dem sander schaffen also ich
habe ihnen definitiven bisschen länger
als drei minuten erhitzt
aber was zählt ist der geschmack
l zum glück mochte ich die torte nicht
weil sonst würde ich einfach alles mögen
was noch alles schmeckt es schmeckt
einfach noch einmal aus der kategorie
musst du noch im ofen selberbacken
christie war papa so sehen sie gefroren
aus und so gebacken
da ist es kein geräusch ich bin ein
grosser kartoffelpuffer fan und wenn ich
erst jetzt auch schaaf kartoffelpuffer
gut zu machen dann weil sie nicht mehr
was er meint hamburger muss ja auch
zucker und zimt oder machen muss wenn
super ja natürlich
natürlich schmecken sie gut was sind
auch sonst steht heißt es ich will den
geschmack herausfinden ich will dinge
kritisieren
ich will sagen das ist gut und das nicht
aber bis jetzt das einzige was nicht gut
war
weil diese komische torte ansonsten
schmeckt einfach alles ich sollte dieses
video anschaut mir dabei zu wie ich 30
minuten lang er tut es ja wir wissen die
rösti es sind lecker aber wir haben auch
zwei sachen vor uns also es kann doch
sein dass mir etwas nicht schmeckt aus
der kategorie kaffee selbst eigentlich
müsste jetzt irgendwas stehen mit
memories apfelkuchen der wirklich schön
präsentiert mit so vanillesoße auch ganz
klasse aber ich will die laktose nicht
zwingend in meinem körper einzudringen
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ich weiß jetzt einfach
mal rein da sind so haferflocken
obendrauf
es schmeckt auch das schmeckt teilweisen
apple.com bin ja ist nicht schlecht aber
es auch nicht super haut mich jetzt
nicht um kommen wir endlich unseren
letzten produkt nämlich schon
bauchschmerzen café depp ist mehrere
muren und lawinen oder was bekommt man
ja auch den schoko also die verpackung
das wirklich interessant so sieht der
affen beachtet nächtlichen schulter
guckt und gramm final sieht eigentlich
aus wie der andere
leider der letzte bissen kuchen mit
sahne erfüllung mangel passt endlich mag
ich was nicht dafür wollte ich unbedingt
diesen chocolate cake ingrid chocolate
cake derer super leute das auch in dem
video ich hoffe sehr euch hat es
gefallen ich hoffe es ist nicht so
chaotisch geworden aber das werden wir
dann sehen wenn es ausnahmen stellen
eine die ohren steif schreibt mir noch
gerne euer lieblings ikea bisher bis
dann läutet